Good morning John. It is the last video of 2009
And it just so happens that my final video of 2009 falls on a song Wednesday
I wrote the lyrics to this song and then sent it to the song-writing musical duo Rhett and Link
and they wrote the music and we recorded the song
together which was really freaking cool
so I'm going to go ahead and play the
song for you and then I will talk a
little bit more after the thingy
Hank, do you remember when all Georgia fled
that flood the left thousand homeless and
seven dead while those people drowned and
their houses went adrift,
the news was about Kanye West and Taylor Swift
But, Rhett and Link where I really seen the news
media failing as every time anyone
mentions Sarah Palin they dispatch a dozen
camera crews every time she poos while
I can't escape the feeling she just not news.
And the swine flu, while a killer, got more love than it needed
killing 4,000 people while the normal flu, unheeded,
kills 60,000 people year in and year out. People like to
have something to freak out about.
And what about the Micheal Phelps marijuana
scandal?
Just one picture and the media flew off the handle.
He did the same thing as our last three presidents.
I don't think our priorities make much sense.
So many important things happened this year,
friend.
Iran's election and mass recession and Obama sworn in.
But to us the
things on cable news seem so freaking dumb.
and we can only hope that we're not
the only ones.
Yes we can only hope that we're not the
only ones.
And I don't think the crappy news
gets any better than
the scandals of Tiger Woods and David Letterman.
It turns out that rich guys cheat on their wives.
That wasn't news in the year 25.
And one of the biggest stories of the whole entire year
is that Susan Boyle could sing and bring and audience to tears.
With all the pretty people autotuned we forgot:
you don't have to be hot to be the talent Britain's got.
And I still laugh every time I see some poor braggart
proudly holding up
a sign proclaiming he's a Teabagger.
besides any confusion about the
revolution,
I think no matter what they mean, the news was an illusion.
So many important things happened this year, friend.
Iran's election and mass recession and Obama sworn in.
But to us the things on cable news seem so freaking dumb,
and we can only hope that we're not the only ones.
Yes we can only hope that we're not the only ones
And I think we three can all agree the biggest load of poo
is that Balloon Boy Falcon who was not in a balloon.
Just another year where we kept
the world alive.
We didn't pay attention, but somehow we didn't die
So many important things happened this year, friend.
Iran's election and mass recession and Obama sworn in.
But to us the things on cable news seem so freaking dumb,
and we can only hope that we're not the only ones.
Yes, we can only hope that we're not the only ones.
But since they're still reporting it...
we just might be the only ones.
Happy New Year Hank!
And the other one...
Your brother
I think his name is Don...
John.
So that was Rhett and Link and this is me and I am telling you people:
if you have not, go check out their work:
There's a link in the sidebar.
And if you want to thank them for kicking ass
and making my final song Wednesday video freaking awesome, go ahead and subscribe.
And they also have an album coming out on January 5th, so you might want to check that out, too.
John and Nerdfighteria, thank you
for making 2009 a really amazing year
for us all.
I could never have expected it to be this great,
but maybe we can
make 2010 even better.
dftba